البدايه بمقال للباحث محمد عثمان في
الجاردين البريطانيه قال في ان القتال
الضاري يجر السودان الى نقطه الانهيار
وتتحمل دول العالم لاسيما بريطانيا
مسؤوليه خاصه لاظهار قياده قويه بما في
ذلك فرض عقوبات مستهدفه على جميع القاده
المسيئين وتوسيع حظر الاسلحه الحالي ليشمل
السودان باكمله وتنقل
الوزير البريطاني السابق لشؤون افريقيا
قوله ان الولايات المتحده تركت فراغا في
افريقيا بعد سلسله من الذبذبات الكبيره في
المواقف بين الرؤساء الامريكيين واضاف ان
التعويل على دبلوماسيه دول الاقليم بشان
احداث السودان اظهر عدم فاعليه واشنطن
ولندن والقوى الاوروبيه الاخرى في افريقيا
وتقول الواشنطن بوست ان بلدان عربيه
مختلفه وخاصه دول الخليج اسهمت في رعايه
رد الفعل المعادي للديمقراطيه ويرى خبراء
ان الغرب لم يلعب دورا ايجابيا في انعاش
الاعمال بتحقيق الديمقراطيه في المنطقه
العربيه وفي السودان بدت الولايات المتحده
اكثر انشغالا في اقناع جنرالات البلاد
باتفاق لتطبيع العلاقات مع اسرائيل بدلا
من توجيه انتقال جدي الى مسار الديمقراطيه
ونقلت التايمز عن المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين القول ان نحو 10
الى 20 الف شخص فروا من اقليم دارفور الى
تشاد المجاوره لكن يعتقد ان الارقام اعلى
بكثير لان الكثيرين غير قادرين على التنقل
في الشوارع المليئه بالجثث وحذر الخبراء
من ان الصراع يهدد بتدمير النظام الصحي
باكمله في السودان لموندا الفرنسيه توقعت
ان يكون الوضع في السودان اكثر تعقيدا
خلال الايام المقبله فيما يتعلق
بالاستجابه لدعوات وقف اطلاق النار واشارت
الى المخاوف والشكوك بشان مصداقيه كل من
مجلس السياده قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقائد القوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميدتي المعروفين بالاستماته
في الدفاع عن مصالحهما حتى النهايه وكتب
موقع
ذهل ان الولايات المتحده تستعد لاجلاء
محتمل لموظفي السفاره الامريكيه من
السودان حيث قامت بنشر قوات اضافيه في
مكان قريب في المنطقه لاغراض الطوارئ
المتعلقه بتامين وربما تسهيل مغادره موظفي
السفاره من السودان اذا اقتضت الظروف ذلك
وكانت تحذيرات امنيه صدرت من السفاره
الامريكيه في الخرطوم افادت بخطوره
الاجلاء واعرب المسؤولون الامريكيون عن
قلقهم البالغ على سلامه الدبلوماسيين
الامريكيين العاملين في العاصمه نختم هذا
العرض مع مجله الاكارمست التي قالت ان
احداث السودان تعكس ابتعاد العالم عن
السلام حيث تستفحل الصراعات وتتمثل اهم
الطرق لتعزيز السلام في بناء مؤسس ات افضل
في الدول الهشه رغم ان ذلك قد يستغرق
عقودا الا انه السبيل الوحيد لان البديل
هو عالم تكون فيه الحياه صعبه في الدول
الفقيره والحرب في العاده تكون طويله
الامد
[موسيقى]